hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to poly bridge and often
suggest a game that I am totally on
board playing I actually played a game
like this on my phone way back when
because I was an engineering nerd and I
love this sort of stuff so you do this
by do that and then you do that and then
you do that and then you start the
simulation and then it goes to an
isometric view like how cool is that and
it's it's a bridge-building game which
not is not awakened uncommon theme in
terms of game but this hopefully is
gonna do in a unique way that's gonna
make it really interesting to play so
with that being said I don't think it's
gonna support the weight of that car I
think it's gonna need to be have extra
split right there oh no it broke
they're all dead instantly everybody in
their family has gone to hell straight
dive box train to hell so obviously we
need a tool wheel we need wood I've
actually never played this before so I'm
just kind of winging it as I go
oh look bridges need support so as an
engineering nerd like I love this store
stuff like I love I used to be a civil
engineer before I was gonna be a
biomedical engineer so we need to build
the road yes we do absolutely we do I
completely agree then we need to get the
wood which tool get the wood oh we're
gonna build a Tris PC we're gonna do
this and I don't I don't need to
constantly click I just need it click
once and I'm good
go go baby go see it's providing support
by being on had it ok triangles are very
good structurally stable thing the arch
is the most structurally stable thing
but I don't know if there's gonna have
arches in it it's probably just gonna
gonna be point point click so with that
being said you need to over we need a
suspension we've to drain to its so with
terrain joints we're gonna have a cable
here or no we're gonna wait start
building a road across with the terrain
joints and wait what
okay I see what's me okay I thought
you're gonna have something else so with
a suspension bridge you need to leave in
Mugu okay on come on Duke come here do
some air oh boy
earlier your own kids the wrong thing I
was like doing the wrong thing I was so
confused I was like what the world is
even happening okay I got it
yeah so in the suspension bridge you
anchor into two points natural landmarks
that are higher up so it's hanging
instead of lifting there's different
types of structural for a bridge you can
either prop it up from the bottom or
prop it up from the top to give it a
simple explanation and you do that
through various methods there's a lot of
different methods by which you can build
a bridge like there's no one way to do
about it that's because there's a lot of
bridges that look different from each
other
but this one uses a stabilizing point of
those totally not gonna fall over rocks
very sturdy very sturdy rocks and then
it supports the weight of the bridge and
distributes it along the entire cable
length which is really cool because you
know okay
time to a drawbridge rectangle amil
shows where Swift will be going through
now this is another challenge in terms
of bridge building because normally
bridges are built on rivers they can be
built over ravines of course but they're
normally built over rivers so they can
cross between two on his land so with
the river you have a lot of ships going
through so how do you keep something
structurally stable and have a moving
SEP section that can go up or down or
move around and still retain the
structural integrity of the entire
bridge that's an interesting totally
interesting thing so with that being
said you build a road first I guess but
I don't think a roads gonna cut it you
need to actually have a different
section that's going to allow it go up
and down where it's needed so thank you
so we're gonna build flip bridge as per
normal like what it would normally be if
we were just building a bridge which is
like it's got both support
and trust so with the hydraulics we're
gonna make that middle part lift up to
clear the red area again I've never
played this game but I love these types
of games just cuz it's fun for a nerd
like me I don't know how it works in
this one but looks like it's gonna work
like that so the double joint bridge
create a split joint needed to open the
drawbridge I agree so we need a bridge
joint XE so ah double click oh never
mind double click there we go done easy
as that so now that's there the
hydraulics can move the bridge is very
stable because it's supporting from the
bottom and it's also got supports on the
natural landmark on the side so the way
the trusses work on a triangle formation
is that it's trying to spread the weight
out words so when the car is in the
middle it is pressing down in the middle
it gets full support from the structures
on the bottom and also because the
weight is pseudo lifted from the trusses
that are pushing down on the sides it
distributes the weight very evenly makes
a very stable thing it's a pretty
typical bridge formation anyway
I'm already gone again sorry sorry
everybody sorry
okay visualize load-bearing stress on
joints this work computer situated
simulations come in handy for bridges
because you have to get this here and
now I'm totally on my own so I probably
have to just build it as I build it is
with most chicle bridges you're gonna
build it as most typical bridges what oh
come on
I thought it would be on my own by now
okay now it's oh it is my turn to
support this bridge so obviously we have
a problem oh it's not gonna reach what
am I gonna do how am I gonna make this
supporting this give me a second I'll
think about that
okay so obviously we learned about you
know standard trusses which are built as
such you need to make sure you keep it
at 45-degree angles because 45-degree
angles triangles or what are they called
new geometry no really what do they call
the opportunity cuz again remember oops
that's not what I want okay so the other
problem here is that oh it doesn't quite
reach that so how are we gonna get that
so what we need to do is we need to
build an intermediary step in this where
we use the grid to judge so you need
four by four understanding of what the
bridge is gonna be and then you build
from there that way you have support of
the bridge from the bottom in a semi
sturdy way but you also have support
from the bridge from the top now you
could also build something but you don't
want to add too much then it causes
weight and I'm pretty close to my
maximum budget here
technically I'm under budget but this is
like the best I can do for what it is
and see no shift no shimmy very sturdy
but I used a lot of budget so in a lot
of things with bridges you can over
build but you really want to build
exactly to what you need plus a lot to
count for wind and weather and stuff
like that
oh you need to do a lot of these things
so to do that we need to try to
understand so let me show you something
else that we could do which is common in
bridges as many of you have seen kid
didn't mean to do that come on
so what I'm doing here is I'm branching
out to two parts of the road from a
single point that puts a lot of stress
on the middle so we want to kind of
alleviate that stress away from the
center point but we don't have enough
budget or we probably don't have enough
budget to go the entire way across the
bridge so I'm fairly sure that we can
actually go just half way and build this
in the middle of it and that distributes
the weight to the outside but I don't
actually that may not work and let's see
if this works
it might work it worked
typically bridges or bridge roads are
sturdier boat sturdier than that with
concrete rebar in that there wouldn't be
all that flex going but we saved money
we didn't use all of it we didn't need
to use all of it so it kind of what what
I did that middle structure in the
middle
it created a distribution because the
middle had the support but you needed
support for the other ones too but you
don't need to go all the way across the
bridge to be able to support it you can
do it just in the middle where it is and
then you can move forward from there as
much as is needed does that make any
sense you still following me signs with
Morgan Blair it's not even sciences is
physics whoops no no oh god no I'll get
me to press that button oh no those poor
families they were just going to Disney
World
oh boy okay so even done up from here
you really have fun with the game
because then you get to do whatever you
want I mean it's not giving me the
suspension stuff yet obviously there's a
lot of solutions to complex problems
that you don't need but this
it's relatively simple see that doesn't
reach all the way so what are we gonna
do we're gonna build actually an
intermediary step in between the two of
these and use it as a joint stress
stress see what I mean
go on and that reaches perfectly their
reach is there is there and that
supports the middle of it and that will
support the middle of it very strongly
oh we still have the problem of the
other parts of the bridge so the
opposite of what I showed you before is
is is able to be shown in a different
structure like it's pretty simple what
its gonna be because it actually is
literally the opposite of it so instead
of looking in the middle you look at the
ends and you want the ends to be able to
support what you got in the middle
instead of the other way around because
we don't need to support the middle the
other one was a shorter bridge so he
could be supported from the middle
instead of doing on both the ends this
way we support everything that we need
and nothing that we don't see what I
mean you will now go go oh die don't die
don't die
you died ok well that didn't work at all
ignore everything that I said I'm a liar
and I should be ashamed of myself
okay so for this one like I said before
and I totally didn't fail and nothing
bad happened at all because engineering
is a guessing game we're gonna see if
this works again it was the same idea
that I had before but I'm willing about
the heavier car it's gonna cause no okay
so obviously the same thing that I said
before worked but I'm pretty close to my
maximum tolerance on that joint stress
so you don't want to over see that and I
actually actually texted before in terms
of failure that maybe or maybe not you
guys saw that the opposite ends of it
would never mind never mind never mind
it all okay now we're climbing an
incline with this we have nothing else
supporting we're still just doing with
road and wood but come the concept is
still the same oh no it's not
never mind
okay all right
wait I had to test that worked I didn't
want to like talk out of my ass here so
but with an incline you have to worry
about a couple things you have to worry
about the vehicle being able to go up
and over where you want to go being able
to go up a hill so you want to make the
hill as gentle as possible
start start steep and even out as it
goes up because if you're going slow and
then you ramp up at the end it's gonna
be much harder for it to overcome the
last bit there so you want to like start
more and then gently curve into there
and the structure it's still the same so
you don't need to worry about it but
what you do need to worry about is the
way that stress is being pulled if if I
like though it works out differently if
I'm at least I think it works out
differently if I'm having all of these
pull from the left as opposed to grab
yeah I was it probably it probably gonna
still work anyway like I'm not I'm not
terribly worried about but like oops
another so if it's all pulling from the
left dad still works
it's still fine yeah
all right so yeah either way like it
doesn't matter but when you're
accounting for a bridge this is a heavy
vehicle so you always need to be mindful
of how the bridge is built in accordance
with where the vehicle is gonna be at
all points across the bridge because the
weight of the vehicle will move entirely
across the bridge fairly evenly but the
points it was the stress effects like
how the how the thing is built so you
could like double-reinforced ease if it
would reach all the way or have like a
middle truss here where you have all
these like go in between or something
like that but the basics of bridge
building are all the same you try to
support the weight as best you can on
your two anchor points that's all there
is to it I'm gonna do one more after
this how might we do never never never
no no hi kids
hey I would love to have an analysis to
see what the stress isn't being able to
see like the stress as a colored version
of it but we'll see
scooter ah skewed Oh we're gonna jump
are we well I had no idea all right then
fine it seems like a weird application
but okay so with the jump trying to curb
up right we're trying to curve up can't
create a more Road okay got it
so so as with most physics lessons the
question is what's the best angle for
the most distance and that's just
question two gravity how far can it go
before it's gonna come back down to the
earth so when you're launching you want
to long you on a very specific launch
angle and the letting go is pretty much
the same in most applications like that
people think it would be 45 degrees and
then they might be right I'm not exactly
sure so we're gonna find out again I
don't talk out of my ass for some reason
I want to say that it's 30 but I'm not
100% sure of that
you
all right I'm wondering I'm wondering if
this is gonna be enough that he could
get across just from a really good go I
don't know how fast he's gonna go so
we'll see go man go go I believe in you
go he made it okay so I'm gonna try this
again at a 45 degree angle because I
want to say thirty I wanted to say
thirty was gonna be better but we'll try
it again at a forty-five degree angle
that's 45 right
yeah that's pretty fun cuz yeah I don't
I don't believe I don't believe it's
gonna be better but we'll see let's see
what happens I still made it he popped a
wheelie - he looked way cooler going 45
to 30 it all depends on like the speed
the angle whatever it is bunch of other
physical body but there's generally
typically we studied it in discus too
like what was the optimal angle for
throwing a distance as far because
you're at a stationary point 45 degree
angle is probably always going to be the
best probably definitely probably
different I say probably definitely
because I can't say for certain cuz I
don't remember it was too long ago I
can't have been an engineer high a lot
of what I'm saying is wrong - oh boy
another jump this is practical everyday
applications so oddly enough what I want
is I want this guy to still be building
up speed before he goes into his jump
so um I don't just want him to jump from
the beginning I wanted to actually
continue on and then launch himself
which actually might be interesting out
let me get that deeper angle
that might actually give him more speed
not sure though that's a lotta that's a
lot of stress that's a lot of stress
let's see what happens let's see what
happens okay didn't work they're dead
they're very dead oh they're very dead
oh my god just the way they Korean into
the ocean is really funny to me oh all
right so this is actually probably gonna
work out a lot better but we'll see
about that
who knows who knows no puzzle like a
right so it's too heavy on this
end but it still needs some support so
okay so the reason the last one failed
is because it buckled and buckling is
generally bad the other option that we
could do is obviously it doesn't have to
all be the weight over here I just
noticed that there actually anchor
points over here because my camera was
over here I didn't notice it so when
this fails and it's going to it's gonna
fail oh yeah it didn't fail okay the
reason why it is succeeded ah is because
when you're when you're doing this not
when you would have to stacked on each
other you have a lot of structural
support straight up and down but you
don't have a lot of a horizontal
strength like it's with concrete
concrete has a lot of compression force
but uh
bending forces I forget would appeal I
forget all the name but I forgotten
everything but horizontal forces it's
not very strong on especially when it's
bearing a lot of loads so that's why it
can be knocked out easily so with this
man with wood instead of when you have a
metal joint you need a triangle base to
focus the way in which access
stabilizing for the force because the
force when the weight is applied
downwards hopefully equals out so that
it doesn't buckle the joint one way or
another so I was able to launch him from
one to the other without actually
building a ramp on the other side
because one I had to make continue to
accelerate going downwards and then they
launched off at a good angle going
upwards and they were able to get enough
distance and somehow they landed on a
job each other the scooter command I'd
probably and then everything went out so
that was how that happened let's watch
that again and dead immediately did so
yeah that is poly brute I have a love
for these types of games just because I
love this sort of site of stuff I love
puzzle games and I like the idea of what
this means and it's a really cool game
calming music really good styling I
think it's cool so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know how
wrong I was about everything that I said
in the comments down below let me know
all the terminology that I'd forgotten
since school let me know just how big of
an idiot I seemed and let me know what
you think of the game at the same time
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
oh man I really want to like this game